we're going for a very naturalistic look
in the lighting and the camerawork and
following the main character AJ in a
very intimate sort of way I did a lot of
research watching other movies that
inspire me in that type of direction
like really a lot of handheld camera or
naturalistic lighting situations and
then you know very character-driven
dramas the script was very precise into
what he needed to be shot then Jeannie
has an incredible knowledge about
basketball and she really wanted to
capture the place and she really wanted
to give the players freedom and we
wanted to capture it with two cameras
and sort of not interfere and be able to
capture the story within the action we
wanted to choose a camera that would
work really well with natural light and
with work well for him health and Alexa
has been a camera that I've worked with
many many times and I think it's a great
choice Amira was her first choice and
then Alexa was our second choice and f55
would have been the third choice we
selected the camera from previous
experiences and we love the way it looks
and we love the workflow and the ability
to handle natural light and it's just a
great camera we were actually donated
the camera by panel Asian so it was
really great well we wanted to use zooms
for the sort of realistic and
naturalistic feeling and just to give
the operators freedom and to be able to
capture the place as they came so we
knew we wanted to and the Optimus are
really great lenses and they're
lightweight we got them from panel Asian
our lenses I'm very happy with the way
it looks I love it
I think there's a real sense of the
world in both the school in the gym and
where AJ plays and deals with the locker
room and
then the world outside when she's coming
out of the school and meeting her dad or
practicing on the court which will be
shooting later tonight yeah I'm pretty
happy with the way we capture basketball
and just immersing ourselves into that
world and I think the realistic approach
was really served the story